re ん
今日は何かですねパワーフロー猫のピッチングマシンを使ってすごいことをしようと
思ってます
ロイは4番
レッドゾーン
ni
勝ちを行くけどなぁ4階
えっはぁ
ボートでいけるんじゃないかな
あっあぁああああ
ああああああ
さぁ続いてじゃあ3人目はい彼ら二人なぁ
次はファイアー
一応スライダーとドロップカーブワーワーブーブー
02使わない男の1本勝負ですよ仕込ん c のストレートロスオーダーい勝ち
ましょう pou dou dou
じゃあ
さえ任命かつ一般プレイヤー代表選手です
scape 自身は位ということなんですが果たして
ラミレスを打ち取ることができるのかラミレスとしてもそろそろヒットが一方欲しい
ところ
打ち気満々のらりです
そのハイリア注目です earth
ゆっくりと送りかぶって濡れた靴場所90分
すぐ千葉賞球口は初級中途中レっとんでー
ani
田村サジット得意の諸経ジェス
増やしそうな3月なんと1球でマウンドを降ります
よがんばってがんばって
水で4人目太郎アゲアゲさ
て僕あの
140キロのストレートをそしてスライダー
うんそしてカーブして落ちる変化球のパーンというのがあって
そして素晴らしいことに超スローボールという4
そういう球があるんですよ遅い球使えそうで2ですね今までなかったですかして
回じゃ行きましょうか
4番手ピッチャーは過労を開け開けですストレートのほかり
超スロードールすライターカードパームた縁です
4種類の変化球を休めませんんだ
こう先ほどもヒットで勢いづいているから3です
集中力を高めゆっくりとバッターボックスに入ります
力強い視線
その目はマウンドを見つめています
さあ先薄らいでいきます
冷静な男ハローアゲアゲまずは初級
このと口ライダー
外角ボールラミレス末は見送りました
では+0
シーズンに脚本安打打率3割100打点
イチローや松井も成し遂げられなかった大記録を持つ最強の助っ人
ここで言って同点に追いつく館
me
引っ張った4スター
ギターの前に forever
ani
ラミレス思わず所竹をあげましたぁーっ
これで同点
甘いストレートを狙い撃ち得意のギャグのちまった
ホラー
me
じゃあそういうことで前になっちゃいますよねレゴやっぱり
tenga
ガツンと決めてもらわないと思うんですよね
に5人目肇社長8
スライダーフォーク
ですねはーい
基本的な能力がじゃいともしれないなるほどなるほどまず切らさて
by 連作ねっやっぱ14040度きてますから
コントロール
f した皆いい
大事なのはハイカラも大事ですけどやっぱココですから
あああいする方法ですから謎も勝負に出て言って以来日経ブーブー言ってやろうかっ
なあああああ
技してどうもストレートです俺様どうぞ
d グレさあ最終回はついに肇社長
抑えのエースにして b じゃあとしての能力は祝目
同点の場面でる鉱山です
チャンネル登録数200万人を超える大人気ユーチューバー
盛り上げる男はランレスに対しやすいですね
サーラ3ですもうパープロピッチングマシンは攻略したのか
よそ
旧名はストレートでマーサパシッと直球でいこうと思います
いくなぁ
おっ
さあいざ勝負
サインが決まったか
注目の初球
th
ananan
マウンドを見つめるのみをそう
ほんと不登校
1球目は
一球目ストレートだったんですけども
弓削ねちょっとお年でフォーク年
ちょっとをとしてみませんかん
性が強いと肇社長最後の勝負に経年法廷きまー
カウントは右腕ストライク
いきドーン
バインダー
ホームランを2回打点を4回超一流選手
ラミレスに対して肇社長注目の2球目です
と正面なしょうところ
家捉えた支援車両
はじめしゃちょー何劣勢きっと取り渋滞中肇社長チーム精霊されば
喜びの道ンギが始まりましたはじめしゃちょーチーム
換金は3階がは伊佐
戦いを置いて
選手たちが整列をしますねこれ
を見ろラミレスしーあめちゃめちゃ右手にバットそして人々に何かを持っても使用を
あなたと夜更は政権はちょっと話があるんですけど
はいはい
てないやゲームものバークリス
同市やががそん亭赤そん亭フュー
m 最後末家投げ5問ハンバッハ
なんと自らのサイン色紙を差し出して牧野もう1イニングを要求です
やりましょう
本当に向けましたマッハ
buster itumi バーディストーンはもう booon o 2- prom
全球ストレート部署をお願いします
前記ストレート背負った
おちょこ場所
いいでしょう真っすぐだけ ok お願いしまーすとかはいおっと腕力
マイバッグをしようと思うよ連休ストレート勝負による延長戦です
昨日延長戦です二行を渡して枚バットの仕様10
全球ストレート総武に持ち込みました屋根0
ラミレス完全に本気ですプライドをかよだが高いです
おおっとマウンドの真島社長を読んでいただしています
ラミレスその目はまさにに羨望安打を放った
現役時代のまなざしそのものです
ホット増のストレート章ぬ保険はい
田中プレート小番ラミレス部があるか
それとも始めさ長の頂部強さがませるのか
力と力のを使い以来
望みです oo
阿蘇市
あれとってます
おっおおっ
注目の1球目えっ
しかし w バック red bar はるーっ
ラミレスのフルスイング
そのバットがうなりを上げています
スイングスピードも早くなってきている
はじめしゃちょーチームはもちろん2がまっすぐそれぞれ
勝負の行方は
ああああああ
goo
えっ me
試合終了
心サクセス等しまう元これキャンセル賞をお願いしました
思わず者らにコンダーレックつらいです
馬場や紅丸料理釈迦と健闘をたたえ合いますっ
ラビリス悔しさのあまりぷないていますここに
息詰まる攻防が幕を閉じました
ということで始め社長チーム対 mix ラミレスの体制は20本中で肇社長チームが
勝利しました
実況は小笠原フェイス所は吉川でお送りしました
それでは熱気冷めやらぬ大和スターチャームからお別れです皆さんさようなら
ます
th